hey guys tim ferrissí author 4-hour
workweek thought i would show you the
three pieces of gear that i travel with
to prevent or fix any type of back pain
and many other types of pain so here
they are the three various tools that I
travel with number one is something
called the rad roller and you can see
here it is very unlike other types of
foam rollers this is the first foam
roller that I've ever traveled with
looks like a knobby tire from a
motocross bike very very helpful in my
case for thoracic spine hips thighs IT
bands and ham strangers when I use them
for most often I travel with this and it
is the first foam roller to give me any
real results so this is number one and
this is something I use every morning
and often times before I go to bed to
trigger I guess would be the
parasympathetic system to help us sleep
Thank You Kelly Starrett for that tip
next we have perhaps the most dangerous
of the three this is the teeter hang up
gravity boot and it hooks onto your foot
just like so almost like a ski boot very
similar to a ski boot with these
bindings and you can see that I have set
up a pull-up bar
made from just straightforward plumbing
construction and you cook on the the
teeter like so and the way that you use
it is putting it on your feet jumping up
and then hooking your lower legs onto
the bar and hanging up sit down needless
to say done incorrectly this can be
extremely dangerous or fatal to do with
proper supervision follow all
instructions etc etc I will generally
only hang for 10 seconds that would be a
set I'll come down hang from the arms
drop down to my feet hanging out for
three seconds do another ten seconds do
very very very short sets if this
doesn't appeal to you you can use a
teeter inversion table or something
called the Linx ly and X which allows
you to do accomplish something somewhat
similar on the ground
alright that's number two number three
is the nyaya acupressure mat and you can
see that this is effectively a bed of
nails and in fact if this is sold out
which after my last recommendation I
think it is
then you can get something called the
bed of nails on amazon or elsewhere
which is very much the same thing and
with this particular device this is
where you put your neck and you lay on
this this was recommended to me by
Audrey bondarenko who is one of the
resident hand balancing and acrobatic
experts with Cirque de Soleil I will lay
on this for five to ten minutes
typically in the morning I'll even put
it on a couch and lay on it while I read
something so those are the three tools
and if you'd like more tips like this
you can check out my free newsletter
five bullet Friday I send out five of
these tips a week the coolest things
that I've found in the last say one to
two weeks and that's just for our work
week calm forward-slash Friday all
spelled out thanks for watching thanks
so much for watching guys and be sure to
consider signing up for my email
newsletter by clicking on email
newsletter because I share private q a's
exclusive content awesome things like
five bullet Friday's which is the five
coolest things i've discovering the
given week exclusively via email and
that's for the die hard that's for the
people who really want the main line of
usefulness and how-to and to really ride
along with me as i learn and discover
the most useful things that I find so
check it out email newsletter click on
it and please let me know what you would
like more of in terms of video in terms
of audio I will try to make it for you
so let me know in the comments and thank
you again for watching